Welcome back I hope that your mental stack has not overflown because of all the recursion
In this second part we'll keep it very light
and in particular I will help you with some of the exercises
that are on the website for this chapter
In the very first lecture we showed
very quickly an implementation of quicksort in Haskell
and what we will do now is we will look in a little bit more detail at quicksort in Haskell
The idea of quicksort is to sort a list recursively
by decomposing the list somehow
recursively sorting those lists
and then combining the results together
If we think about that for a little bit, we can say:
if I have the empty list it's already sorted
Now how do we recurse
how do we break up that list into two parts that we can recursively sort
and then easily combine the results to get a sorted list?
Well what we do is if we can take a look at the head of the list
and break this list in two, one with all the values that are less or equal than the head
One with all the values that are greater than the head
Then we can just recursively sort those two lists
and inject the head in the middle and we're done
That's the algorithmic essence of quicksort
but as I already warned you
in the real implementation you're not creating new lists
you're really mutating the data structure in place to swap the elements
and that's an aspect that this version of quicksort doesn't show
but it does show this recursive structure
Alright, here's the implementation of quicksort
similar to the very first lecture
and only now it's called quicksort instead of f
What we do when we have the empty list: it's already sorted
When we want to sort a list x cons xs
we create a list with all the elements that are smaller or equal than x
and for that we use a list comprehension
We create a list of all the elements that are larger than x
We sort both of those and we put x in the middle
This is a very simple implementation of quicksort
but again it's also a very simplistic implementation of quicksort
But if you want to understand the structure
this is probably a very good illustration
If we want to illustrate how this works
let's abbreviate quicksort as q
such that the slide doesn't overflow
We want to sort the list [3, 2, 4, 1, 5]
What we're going to do is we're taking the head three
and we're going to break up the rest of the list into the elements that are less than equal to 3
and the ones that are larger than three
The elements that are less in this list are two and one
And the ones that are larger are four and five
That's what you see, we recursively sort those
and we inject three in the middle
If we sort the list [2, 1]
we take the head, we split the remaining list, which is just one
into the values that are smaller and the values that are larger
The ones that are larger that's the empty list
The ones that are smaller that's one
and then we drop two in the middle
Same on the right hand side
we take the first element
and we split the remainder of the list which is just 5
in the elements that are larger than four so that's the list 5
and the elements that are smaller which is the empty list
and we inject four there in the middle
The empty lists here and here
are already sorted so nothing to do there
We just have to short the list of one element
and you can verify that when you sort the list of one element it returns that list itself
If we make those recursive calls there we get this list
and now you see that the result is one two three four five
You just walk that tree to get the results
That was quicksort
The exercises for this week there's a lot of exercises to define functions recursively
but I'm going to do just a couple of them here with you
Let's look at the first one here
It says produce a list with n identical elements so
that's a function that takes an integer which is the n
and then it takes a value a
and it should return a list of n copies of that value a
How do we do that?
Well we do that by not recursing, well we don't recurse over this a
and we have to build the list,
so what we have to do is we have to define this recursively over the structure of this integer
so again we have two cases
n equals 0, if I replicate an element 0 time,
I get the empty list so that case is easy
If I want to replicate a value n times, what do I do?
I first replicate it n minus one times
so I get the list of n minus one times as
and then I cons a on top
That one is easy
but again you have to look a little bit
and then you see: I'm doing recursion over that guy
there's two cases just write them down and everything drops out
Here is another friend of us that we've seen in previous lectures
and there I warned you that in Haskell lists don't have constant access
When we implement this function that will be very clear
What we have to do is we have to take a list and a number and then return the element in that list at that position
Of course we can do this using a take or drop or other functions but the goal here is to define it using recursion
Since we have here two recursive structures
the list and the integer
we're going to define this by recursing over both
How would that look
well first thing is if we want to have the zero'th element of the list
well that is the head of the list
If I have a list x cons xs and this one is zero
then that's the element For the first element of the list is the element at index 0
That's a simple one
If the list here is empty
well what do we do That's a good question
probably if I want to index the nth element of the empty list
that's going to give an error
Let's not worry about that, we're going to put that as the last clause
Now we can assume that this one is not zero and this one is not empty
If that one was zero we're done
if that one was empty and this one is not zero then we have an error
Now they're both non-zero so what we do
is we say: okay if this is x cons xs and this is n
what we do is we take the index of the tail of the list and the n-1 index
Simple recursion too, it's just that we have to be a little careful about the base cases
The last function we're going to define using recursion here
decides if a given value is a member of a list
Of course we could cheat here and not use recursion
We can easily use filter or list comprehension or something
but the goal here is to define this function using recursion
In this case there's an obvious candidate to do the recursion over, that's this list
If we're looking for an element a in the empty list, that's false
That element is not in the list
If we're looking for an element a in the list x cons xs
well we have to check whether the head of the list is equal to the value that we're looking for
If that's the case we return true
If that's not the case then we just search for that element in the tail of the list
Eventually the tail of the list will be empty
so we will hit the base case and we're done
Now you see here that since we're checking equality of this element each head of the list until we find it
the type a must support equality and that's what you see here in the type
So we can only search for a value in a list
if the types of the list support equality
and that's why we get this constraint here so a must be a member of the type class Eq of a
Great, I hope that this helped, these small exercises
and as I said: on the website
there's a lot of exercises where you will do recursion
and if you get stuck try eating a banana and maybe it helps
Or maybe you can two eat bananas
and that will work even better See you next week